what up gq miguel here i'm at the crib
we're about to go undercover on the
internet
this is actually me
first up twitter let's see what the
family's asking to see
here we go swipe nice little swipe
action hey miguel when you're coming out
with another album i miss you i missed
you too man i missed putting out music i
was just having this conversation
it's been a challenge you know trying to
adjust to the times to be honest with
you but i'm ready
so by the end of this year expect
another project boom
do you have a list of songs that you
want to experience live i have a whole
list for instance can you imagine being
at a miguel show and that bass from
anointed hits your chest
ah as though i live for that i'm having
concert with draws i feel like we all
are i need live music
i need it yeah same same songs i would
love to experience
live man i would love to experience any
james brown live
anything led zeppelin i saw prince live
when he was
when he was with us in this dimension at
least there's a lot though
a lot of artists but i feel you i'm
having concert with draws
performing and attending so hopefully we
can get back to that real soon
posted you know what i need another
miguel janelle monae collab
man janelle big shout out to janelle i
missed you now man
she's been killing it on film and tv
though so um
happy for her i'd love to do another
collab with janelle man we should we
should try and make that happen
gq can we make that happen next one
so miguel auditioned to be draw on
insecure hbo
i had prepared and for whatever reason i
stayed late the night before i'll never
forget this
i stayed in studio the night before
super late
woke up late rushed to the audition and
i think they could tell that i was sort
of like
out of it so issa she's such a
sweetheart she's like can we get you
anything i was like
some food and everybody started laughing
needless to say i didn't get the role
this is the homie i love everyone over
there i love the show so
i'm actually really glad that i didn't
get the role my man
that that actually played drug killed it
so there's that
next one miguel and ozine are body hair
and couple style ghosts yes or yes i
would say yes
yes absolutely
it's all hard though i'm sorry man goals
you should be your own goals first and
foremost i'm a firm believer that it's
always about
just doing it better you know doing your
best bettering yourself
doing it better than you did the day
before that's a big one but we we also
like to focus on showing up for
ourselves in terms of
you know meditation and making sure that
we're in the right mind state to just
deliver to deliver on whatever it is
that we're passionate about so
you know hopefully um that helps you
kind of reframe it you know we don't
want to be your goals we want you to be
your goals
hopefully we can keep reminding each
other what's possible and do it better
day by day next one how'd i know that
miguel is a scorpio i don't know
is it obvious is it obvious i mean i
have two scorpions tattooed across my
collarbone so
that doesn't make it hard to guess but
um yeah i'm very proud of my scorpio
tendencies
i like to think that i'm an evolved
scorpio though i'm trying to grow out of
any like
jealous tendencies any possessive habits
and i think that's been something that's
been cool to learn especially in my
friendships
and my relationships it's been really
cool to kind of grow out of some of the
the lower frequency vibes but i i do
love it that i'm very passionate about
everything that i do i love
hard i work hard i fight hard
i believe big i think that has a lot to
do with my scorpioness
yeah yeah very proud scorpio here all
right next one
miguel and rihanna collab make it happen
i'm about that collab
i'm about that collab too we've spoken a
couple of times the last time i saw rui
was actually in studio
what was it i was in studio i was
working with hip boy and that's this
year that's crazy
and we ran into each other at the studio
and you know again we just kind of like
yo we have to do something so i guess
it's always just about timing
and the right song which means that it's
inevitable
next section this is youtube
[Music]
this zone function is perfect okay
[Music]
am i the only one who thinks miguel
would be perfect fit to portray prince
in a biopic or is it just me how do you
how do you pronounce that word is it
biopic or is it biopic i don't know
man playing prince prince already played
prince
in purple rain remember i was raised on
his music and i think he
has always been sort of the epitome of
an artist
no artist better exemplifies what true
artistry
means and is and and the dedication
and excellence levels i don't think
anyone better exemplifies that than
prince and i will wager
a lot to say that most artists would say
the same
i think because of my respect for that
yeah i don't i don't know
but if we're talking about a
hypothetical film i'd be honored
honestly
i'm not saying i would actually do it
i'm just saying hypothetically speaking
[Music]
i have questions about this album cover
how did they do that did his back get
[ __ ] up when he landed on the sand
did his elbows get hurt all right fun
fact i'm actually
laying on sort of like a bench a really
thin
bench and it was a [ __ ] trying to like
keep the pose it's actually like
a lot of core work i'm really happy that
i had worked out a couple weeks
in advance and got some more work in
because it was tough and it took us a
while to get it right
so that and a little bit of photoshop
kind of gives a disappearance
next what does this song mean
he's talking about funeral one of my
favorite things that kurt cobain said
in an interview he's like i'm not gonna
explain what the songs mean
it's not what it's about you know and i
think one of the things
that i've done in the past that i wish i
didn't do was like explain the songs
because it takes all the fun and the
imagination and the ownership
away from the listener i think it's
really cool to listen to a song
and find your own meaning in it
this is also regarding funeral find a
music video for this masterpiece
and this is when it came out in 2019
which is crazy but there is a video
on the way that's loading boom
cora
[Music]
what makes miguel singer so cool and
chill man
ah i've got a big heart strong-minded
but i'm also open-minded i make what i
want i do what i want and it always
comes from the right place
i can admit when i'm wrong and i like to
have a good time
yeah moving on
wikipedia
[Music]
trip miguel was born and raised in san
pedro
los angeles i was raised in san pedro
yes but i was born in linwood california
which is kind of
a lesser-known city kind of going to be
from i like to know about linwood but
that's where i was born
at a young age miguel was introduced to
the older r
b his mother listened to and his
father's musical tastes including funk
hip hop jazz and classic rock
my mom where she was listening more to
artists like stevie wonder and the
temptations and anything that was coming
out of motown
my dad was like all over the place he
was listening to the eagles and the
beatles and
jimi hendrix like nirvana the fuji's
p-funk
and crazier bands like the deftones some
punk bands
all my stuff kind of plays a lot into
the music that i make more so because
there's really no boundaries and i'm
always kind of pulling from all these
different
sonic palettes and tones to kind of
incorporate into my own music
miguel cites musicians prince david
bowie jimi hendrix freddie mercury phil
collins donnie hathaway b.i.g
kanye west saul williams queen usher
pharrell williams influences
yeah it is pretty pretty broad of a
range of influences but it's true
i look to songwriters like alanis
morissette for songwriting
and bjork nina simone i've been kind of
jumping back into like a lot of female
writers and artists lately
everything i didn't really get to jump
into that wasn't a part of
projected radio culture in the 90s which
is when i grew up
i'm kind of like revisiting so a lot of
that includes a lot of incredible female
artists so that's what i've been
listening to lately and influenced by
lately miguel played a cuban american
gangster in ben affleck's period crime
drama
live by night this is very true he
covered beyonce's crazy
love for the theatrical trailers for
fifty shades darker also true and
actually got to
work with one of my like mentors i would
say dave siddiq on that song
but also i produced this song for coco
remember me that's on the soundtrack
that won
an academy award which is excellent
incredible to be a part of you know
disney's like that's legendary i also
got to work on
another song for a soundtrack on the
hunger games series and a song i did
with lord
but yeah there's a lot more miguel
partnered with revolve
impact and headline schools not prisons
tour along with other musicians to
spread awareness
of mass incarceration throughout
california this is true
it was really awesome to work with
schools now prisons and i'm still
supporting their work
obviously a hot topic especially
considering the current temperature and
unfortunate
lives that have been lost children dying
in these
in these prisons this music video for
now was filmed in adelanto
which is the location of california's
largest immigration processing center
the adelanto detention center
it was crazy to go there because when
you're standing outside of it
it just looks like you know a huge
warehouse and it's
in the middle of the desert a small town
learning about the way that
these jails are put up was really
interesting they often choose
you know locations that are remote in
cities that have populations that are
looking for work
they pretty much offer them jobs at
these remote locations
and also kind of place them there to
stay out of the way and
away from attention it really changed a
lot for me it started a big shift in
seeing what was possible when you have
an audience i think from then on
i've been really keen on looking at how
i can
bring attention to things that you know
really matter grateful for that
experience man
miguel has said that transcendental
meditation correction
just meditation not transcendental
meditation is the key to balancing his
lifestyle
and they quote it's good to take a
breath from everything and just center
yourself
that's the best way of describing it i
don't want to like misquote any science
but one of our normal reactions to
stress
is shallow breathing whether it's like
physical stress or
mental stress or emotional stress we
sort of respond in a more shallow way of
breathing
and one of the easiest ways to sort of
come back that and be able to sort of
reassess and take a little more control
reframe things
in a more present way is by catching
yourself
and watching your breath working and how
and paying attention to how you breathe
and
that's changed so much for me just that
one bit of
sort of information i learned it through
meditation because it's a huge
huge part of getting into a more present
place in your mind separating yourself
from the past or kind of looking into
the future because the only thing we can
do about anything
happens right here in the moment that's
a really important one meditation
try it submit well as we all know the
internet is
undefeated it was really dope to be
undercover and see what the questions
were and figure out whether or not the
internet's got it right and i have to
say for the most part
this time the internet was right but
it's time for me to go
so i'm gonna let you guys have the rest
of your day i hope you're well thank you
for watching
peace to gq i'm gonna get out of here
peace